but we begin with nasty weather on both
coasts in California more than 30
million people are currently under flood
alerts including many already hit by
deadly rain earlier this month meanwhile
a nor'easter is dumping wet heavy snow
across New England more than two feet
fell in parts of Massachusetts we've got
correspondence on both sides of the
country but we will begin with Donya
Bacchus in California Dona good morning
what can you see
good morning to you Michelle the road
into this Ventura neighborhood is washed
out the water is nearly as high as the
speed limit side and we've been told
that the residents on the other side are
now using an emergency back road to
leave another brutal atmospheric River
has made a steady March from the
northern to the southern part of the
state nearly 27 thousand Californians
are under evacuation orders and many do
not know when they'll be able to get
back home
Relentless rains pounded Southern and
central California Tuesday flooding
roads in Ventura Northwest of Los
Angeles further stressing snow-packed
rooftops in the San Bernardino Mountains
as a swollen Creek forced evacuations in
San Luis Obispo County it's definitely
higher than it's ever been in my
lifetime that's after pummeling the
state farther north causing a Mudslide
that slammed into this house north of
Sacramento
yeah the high winds toppled a big rig on
a bridge North of San Francisco and
farther south caused these huge
eucalyptus trees to smash into four
buildings in this condo complex no one
was hurt the tree just fell down and
then we got knocked on from the fire
department and the police department to
evacuate as soon as possible
about a hundred people were trapped when
flood waters washed out roads and
bridges into Leary County we did airlift
into multiple points across the County
emergency food rations the latest storm
also delivered another round of rain to
communities close to Rivers already
overflowing thousands of residents in
the farming town of Pajaro were forced
to evacuate in the middle of the night
last week after a levee broke hundreds
have been staying at this full
evacuation shelter for five days and
still can't go home as Anais Rodriguez
told our Carter Evans the thing is that
they don't let us in so that's the part
that's really frustrating you don't even
know your home is okay that's correct
there has been of course rain still
coming and there are now emergency
declarations in 40 California counties
and though this latest round of storms
has been devastating there have been no
reports of injuries or deaths Tony
it's hard not to know if your house is
okay Dania thank you very much for that
report